parlons internet ce soir et d'un site
qui suscite beaucoup d'intérêt il
s'appelle facebook est derrière ce nom
se cache en fait une sorte de
trombinoscope à l'échelle mondiale tout
le monde peut donc s'inscrire et
retrouver ainsi des amis vous êtes déjà
des millions d'utilisateurs à travers le
monde un succès qui attire vous allez le
voir toutes les convoitises
emmanuel lambert mathias barrois
facebook
huit petites lettres synonyme de
révolution plus de 50 millions
d'utilisateurs à travers le monde c'est
clair ce site gratuit connaît un succès
exponentiel
d'abord vous devez créer un profil en
clair c'est votre fiche de
renseignements nom prénom âge profession
loisirs libre à vous de tout dire ou de
tout cacher ensuite vous pouvez étendre
votre réseau et pour retrouver des amis
un petit clic suffit trouver des aides
maternelles n'avait pas vu depuis au
moins 15 ans et j'avais perdu toute
trace de et eric du coup savoir si l'on
fait et l'héroïsme maintenant revoir
leur leurs fautes de leurs photos
ressemblent pour ça l'autre force de
facebook réunir des milliers
d'applications sur un seul site
mais il partage de vidéos de photos
agenda petit jeu ici vous pouvez tout
faire
peut donner des surnoms sympa la déco
par des clins d'oeil à ce qu'on a fait
dans le kent
un rendez-vous pour instiller le
créateur de facebook c'est lui mark
zuckerberg étudiants à harvard 24 ans en
2004 il bidouille incident dans sa
chambre son objectif relier tous les
étudiants de son université rapidement
tous les campus américains se retrouvent
en ligne et en mai dernier il ouvre son
réseau social au monde entier at fait
sport avec facebook
nous voulons créer un monde encore plus
ouvert facebook peut aussi avoir une
utilité professionnelle pierre-yves
tiers c'est un jeune patron spécialisé
dans la vente de piscines
il s'est d'abord inscrit pour les
copains mais le boulot là très vite
rattrapé c'est qu'il ya trois jours j'ai
j'ai été démarché par fut sur facebook
par un potentiel des nouveaux
fournisseurs depuis quelques semaines
vent de révolte chez les utilisateurs la
publicité s'est introduite sur facebook
pire son créateur a vendu tous les
profils aux publicitaires sanctions
certains ont tout bonnement quitté le
site
mais avec deux cent mille nouveaux
inscrits par jour facebook se porte bien
l'entreprise paie serait actuellement 10
milliards d'euros